today during the Game Developers
Conference AMD announced the Radeon Pro
duo which they're calling the world's
first content creation platform aimed
squarely at the VR developer this takes
the form of a dual GPU featuring two
fury x class graphics cards running side
by side making it absolutely the most
powerful graphics card in the world by
far that's the description
AMD marketing executive Chris hook used
to explain the new board which is
principally focused on virtual reality
rather than just doing another
workstation card we actually started
about a year ago we sampled VR
developers about what they'd like to see
from a VR card
he said AMD wondered what would happen
if we took professional workstation
class drivers and gaming drivers and
fuse them together to create a platform
that would not only give you great
scaling across previz and post rendering
platforms but would also be a great
gaming platform the answer is the Radeon
Pro duo dual GPU for VR specifically the
fact that it has two distinct graphic
chips on one card will help reduce
latency a key point for VR developers
AMD is investing so heavily in VR
because it sees a future beyond gaming
alone the company has already formed a
partnership with the associate press for
a newsgathering VR app whilst it's
partnered with Fox Studios for a VR
experience based on the upcoming
Assassin's Creed film that hits this
winter AMD is also working with the
Smithsonian for a VR app that will take
you to the dunes of Kitty Hawk North
Carolina where the white brothers took
their first flights this Radium pro duo
also makes use of AMD's liquid VR
framework while it boasts an incredible
16 teraflops of compute performance it's
coming early quarter to 2016 and will
carry a price tag of $1,500 so will you
be picking up the shiny new card for
your VR machine let us know in the
comment section below and for all the
technical specifics of the radium pro 2
oh and all the news from GDC keep tuned
in to GameSpot calm